this is funny but then somebody said
that she had a stroke so I'm like oh
maybe not so funny but a lot of new
details this morning about that Los
Angeles television reporter who suddenly
began slurring Her speech and speaking
gibberish in her report on the Grammys
the video of serene Branson quickly went
viral on andry hits now on the internet
there are no shortage of theories that
this was just that this was more and
she's having a stroke to here we
go well a very very heavy heavy bir
tonight we had a very Dar darrison bite
let's go hit ter t look for the bit they
have the pit it's almost
painful dude and they said there's no
evidence except for she was just like
kind of [__] out of
it it said it's not a stroke
dude dude the confidence the regular
face if you were listening to this on
mute you'd be like oh just a newscasting
you know but D but
d
B Dar just [__] it up
royally dude just
[__]
just dude you know what she said in
there that you couldn't hear I guess I
quit now because she couldn't she knew
she was fired and she was just like I
guess I'll just quit but she couldn't
even say it shortage of theories that
this was just that this was more than a
bad case that's so weird she [__] that
up here we go well a very very heavy
heavy burtation tonight dude
burtation a very heavy burtation a very
heavy burtation dude I got to talk to
this woman what did what did she
mean it says onair mystery reporter
garble podcast uh broadcast podcast we
had a very Dar darrison B let's go to
ter darrison dude went to school with
him in New Jersey Tas for the they have
the pet it's almost painful watch at
first Serene Branson seems impaired or
nervous but take another look we had a
very Dar darrison B let's go terce Tas
look for the the have the pet online
some are speculating it could be a I
mean dude there's one part where she
went dude she did there's one part where
she goes watch I'll point it
out very heavy heavy dtation tonight we
had a very Dar darrison bite let's go
toit ter Tas for the bit there right
there right there oh dude it's so great
I hope she's okay this was 900 years ago
but oh 12 years
ago I happened look at the comment I had
this happen in high school once it was
terrifying I couldn't get anything out
and everyone thought that I was just
being silly I was told at the time it
was Aphasia yeah but now that I've done
more research I
know it was a condition called Tia
random and non-damaging caused by
migraines or blocks of air flow to the
brain also known as mini strokes okay
that's scary it was just like hers but
lasted for hours what the [__] couldn't
write anything either oh my God imagine
for hours oh my god
dude I'm G that's going to happen to me
I'll do a whole podcast that way it was
so terrifying not be able to communicate
and say that something was wrong it was
the worst experience of my life I get
that I understand that try being
canceled and I have a
rarishock video I have never been able
to find a clip of somebody else talking
like I had it gives me cold sweat just
watching a wow dude I get the clicks
dude I get the clicks I see it and I get
the clicks I saw something that said
news anchor fired after being caught
live on TV daydreaming
dude that sounds like something I want
to click man I got the
clicks oh wow come on here we
go worst song of all
time now to Sport with sh oops news
anchor Natasha exelby was caught off
guard while doing a live news report in
Australia when the News segment ended
and the cameras returned to the reporter
she was caught spacing out while dude
she she didn't need to react like that
if she didn't react like that she
wouldn't have got fired I thought it was
a joke now to Sport with mer the Shan
she recovered pretty well she did sports
news of the day as police continue their
investigation the Reports say exlb has
been relieved of her onair role News
Channel says that she was not a staff
member and was just a casual contributor
details of her employment are
confidential but the journalist found
the humor in the viral moment tweeting
thank you
okay who cares you know